JAKE: OK, Paul, I want to talk
to you about font rendering.
PAUL: [SINGING] Ah!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE: So you visit a site.
Everything downloads-- the
HTML, the CSS, the JavaScript,
but not the font
for the content.
What happens?
PAUL: You'd stare at a
white screen normally.
JAKE: Well, it depends
on the browser, you see.
So in Safari, for instance, it
will give you all the layout,
everything, but it will
block rendering of that text.
PAUL: I thought it did
that in Chrome as well.
JAKE: Chrome does
something similar.
We used to do exactly that.
But we took a cue
from Firefox, and we
decided we'll have
a 3-second timeout.
And then we'll render
the fallback font,
and when the new font comes in,
we'll swap it to the new one.
PAUL: I definitely
have two problems then.
One--
JAKE: You have way
more than two problems,
but I guess you're talking
about two specific problems.
PAUL: To this, yeah.
I mean, that's all the therapy
time we have for today.
Hahaha, folks.
Firstly, 3 seconds feels
really arbitrary to me.
I'm not sure where
that comes from.
JAKE: I trust they did research.
PAUL: And then the
other thing about it
is switching fonts
really bothers me.
Like if you're halfway through
reading a sentence and then
the font changes, it's got a
completely different metrics,
then [POOF] what's that?
JAKE: Yeah, that's horrible.
Words can swap from
one line to another.
It's--
PAUL: Ew!
JAKE: It's bad.
So I think this is
part of the promise
is that there is
no one true answer.
Like even what we do,
you know, what Firefox
is, what Opera does, it feels
like a compromise, which
is sometimes the worst
of all worlds, right?
We've got the delay.
We also have to swap sometimes.
PAUL: Yeah.
OK, fair enough.
JAKE: Thankfully, and the
new CSS property is arriving.
Well, I say it's arriving.
It is being proposed.
PAUL: OK.
JAKE: So it's a bit early
to say it's arriving.
PAUL: Yeah.
Wee!
JAKE: It's a proposal by
Kenji Baheux and Ilya Grigorik
It's on GitHub at the moment.
PAUL: Oh, those two.
JAKE: The worlds of
performance and funk combined.
PAUL: [SINGING] Ah!
JAKE: But it's a CSS
property font rendering,
and you get to pick
what strategy to use.
Like how long do you
want to block for?
Do you want to swap?
Do you want to use a fallback
and then swap the new font in?
It also gives you the option
if you use another technique.
And this is one that
we've seen pioneered
by-- I think it was "The
Guardian" that did it first.
They use the font if they have
it, like if it's in the cache.
If it's there, they'll use it.
If it's not, they just
go for a fallback.
They download the font,
but they don't swap.
They download it.
They put it in local
storage for next time.
PAUL: OK.
JAKE: But this is a
great example, I think,
of the extensible web that
we've seen people do this.
You've always seen
"The Guardian" do it,
"Smashing" Magazine
do it now as well.
And other people have-- you
know we've picked up on it
and think, well, let's
remove the bad bits.
Let's avoid the amount
of code we need to write.
Let's avoid the
local storage bit.
Let's have a CSS
property for it.
PAUL: Love it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE: I've been at a few
conferences recently.
PAUL: Yep.
JAKE: And you know how
the conference after-party
is a great place for developers
to come together and chat
about things.
So we'll put the
music really loud
to really get the
conversation flowing.
PAUL: Exactly.
So nothing says
quality conversation
like shouting at another human
being from a couple of feet
away.
JAKE: Right.
So I was chatting
with this guy, and he
was giving me his
opinion on a thing.
And as he was shouting, a bit
of spit came out of his mouth.
PAUL: Oh.
Where did it land?
JAKE: In my ear.
It was a shot that
Luke Skywalker
would've been proud of.
Like it just when [WHOOSH]
right in the hole.
PAUL: Use the force,
Luke. [WHOOSH] [SPLAT] Ah!
JAKE: Yeah.
And you know that if like
you get water in your ear
then sounds sort of
[IMITATING SOUND UNDERWATER].
[LAUGHS]
There was so much spit in
my ear that that happened.
PAUL: Go on.
What was your exit
strategy for this, then?
JAKE: Well, no,
It was really just
to kind of politely
sort of go, no, yeah.
Yeah, no, that makes sense.
You should do some proposing.
You should definitely
write that up.
I'm just going to
the toilet now.
I'll be back in a minute.
And then a calm, collected walk.
PAUL: Don't run.
Don't run.
JAKE: Don't run.
And then as soon as the
door opened, run to the sink
and like [AH] I've got to
get this out of my head!
PAUL: Hodge podge.
JAKE: It's a dangerous
world, conferences.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE: Yes.